the health and safety protocols have
been published and a man who's been all
over this the pandemic story and
certainly on the NBA he is joining us
from the athletic as well as the stadium
NBA insider shamsher on ER here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you I am rich I
appreciate you having me on hope you and
your found they're safe we are thank you
are you going to Orlando are you
preparing to head down and be part of
that tier one bubble yeah I really don't
know to be honest like I throughout this
whole pandemic I don't know about you
rich broad trusses live day to day
because you don't know what happens next
week or the week after that it feel like
every week is a different week that's
something new that comes up every week
like you know at the beginning of
pandemics like the coronal bar situation
was was you know in and of itself the
most major moment of my lifetime and so
after that you have the murder of George
Floyd and and the racial tension that
that's come out after that like it's
been one after the other so you know
what we'll see we'll see I don't know
yet no I know and obviously you know
what you're you know I shouldn't ask
that because it might not be up to you
it might be up to obviously your
employer whether to send you or not and
times are as you point out unique to say
the least is the NBA has has just put
out this a health and safety protocol
list what left out at you first up yeah
it's a great question there was a lot
you know some of the things were
basically to me it's it's how far the
NBA is going to make this a truly
closed-off safe environment like if you
leave you have severe penalties you know
you declares what I'm told do not want
to go through the invasive nasal swab
well if you leave in you're caught not
only we have to go through the 10 to 14
day quarantine not only do you have to
register two consecutive negative tests
but you also have to go through the
invasive nasal swab testing in the
enhanced testing as they called it no
they have rings potentially up to two
rings that can one tell you if you're
within six feet of another person
another ring that can tell you if you
know early detection of corona virus and
there's a there's a wristband that that
these that
the campus is supposed to wear and and
that will allow you to basically enter
different security checkpoints access
your room after criminal bars testing
but you know how much will the
monitoring doable if you used as a
tracking device which the NBPA and the
mb a-- had completely shut down like
there's just so many different protocols
rich that is it's a lot and then and
then there's you know thirty five
members of a traveling party per team
therefore required positions you have to
have an athletic trainer a couple other
key positions and then if a player
chooses to have his own masseuse his own
security guard his own trainer with the
team like they can make an exception for
a player so you know Odyssey LeBron
James is that his own people at
different points Chris Paul's eyes on
people I don't points like all these
star players have had their own people
around them so well one of those guys
make that make the cut for this to the
traveling party that will be interesting
to monitor so it's a lot richer
definitely a lot to being a put into
that this was a process that took months
it isn't mrs. well rumor throughout the
NBA and we were just kind of waiting for
this to drop and they and it's not a
night so now what's the next step here
does the Players Association have to
negotiate some of these out or some of
these in with the with the board of
management I guess with the with the NBA
and then and then we're all good and
then we're really this is really
happening I mean despite Kyrie Irving
zooms and things of that nature I mean
this is really happening next steps yeah
this is this prologue health and safety
protocol is 113 page package has been
fully approved by the NBA and the NBPA
so okay she's done EA
barring any any unforeseen setbacks they
are moving forward to a season that is
the plan for everyone involved
but again the June 24 date that players
have to notify their team by on whether
they will play or not because every
player is given a choice if you don't
play and you're not excused you're not
going to get paid but there won't be any
other penalty you won't be suspended for
conduct detrimental the team
so that decision will rest on every
individual player so the show is going
on the boat is going to continue to sail
you know we'll see if that you know III
do think there will be some players I
don't know how many that is because it
could be a couple it could be five it
could be a dozen that could decide not
to play just based on what's going on in
the country corner virus pandemic family
issues a lot of different things that go
into it but you know the boat is going
if players want to get off the boat
they're there they're free to but as far
as everything I've been told this is the
packet that has been fully agreed at
senior NBA insider for the athletic
stadium NBA insider shams Terraria here
on the Rich Eisen show okay then so what
happens when when there's a game
there's no masks required around the
bench area and I guess we're just
figuring that that everything's going to
be handled best they can at the hotel
and hotel transportation to game level
that if that's all locked up that when
it's time to play a game we're just
going to just lose ourselves in the
competition and Health and Safety let
the chips fall where they may is that
basically the way it is yeah you know go
back to your point about mask you know
the players on the first roll the bench
are not going to be required to wear
masks the coaches will be heavily
recommended to wear masks so you might
see some of your favorite coaches again
it'll be optional but some of your
favorite coaches might be wearing masks
during this and the second roll of the
bench
everyone was everyone must wear a mask
unless a player is active and just so
happens would be sitting in that second
row because there isn't enough space on
the first row so you know there will be
heavy protocol basically everyone else
will be wearing masks unless you're
playing in the game or unless you're a
referee um there will be a lot of
disinfecting going on not only Disney
staffers but you know the NBA you're
gonna have their own people around
situation and you know this to me is
going to be the ultimate you call it a
bubble the NBA wants call it a campus no
it is very severe it's very drastic
we'll see how much of it it'll it'll you
know what will be
you know lenient on the MBA well like if
if someone really leaves the bubble you
know if LeBron James or James Harden
leave the bubble you know that player to
ask me like what happened like how can
the league you know quarantine them for
10 or 14 days so these are the types of
things that are TVD like we'll see how
the league plays out be struggling what
if players start you know calling them
the anonymous tip hotline and saying
that hey this guy violated this rule of
this it's like you just you don't know
where this could go until we actually go
through with this this is so
unprecedented now shams are you
insinuating that somebody's gonna be
calling the tip hotline before Western
Conference Finals game 7 to say I saw
LeBron out of the bubble last night is
that what you're saying that somebody
might actually do such a thing is this
what you're saying I mean rich the
option is available for them at their
disposal so you know these guys yeah I
saw that
I tweeted out what's it when are they
gonna set up the James Doohan hotline
when can I call to report him yeah
where's where's that hotline I don't
know if you saw my retweet of your your
tweet chance but I'm like yes I'd like
to her I'd like to report the worst
owner in the history of sports by the
way it's not anonymous with me I put my
name to it so I guess again this is all
part and parcel of what's workable and
what's not but there is again an
agreement on the part of players and
owners commissioner and television
partners and every but this is going to
happen is there anything that you're
hearing obviously the virus is is
something that would no question change
this whole dynamic what are you hearing
about because again you've been covering
the pandemic expertly as well for
Stadium and and and the athletic what
are you hearing about any new technology
you mentioned a bracelet that can tell
about the onset potentially of of kovat
19 I read about the Sacramento Kings
owner talking about sort of a
breathalyzer that you breathe into a
tube and within seconds it can be a test
that is reliable to see if you have
kovat 19 or not what are you hearing
about on this front
yeah the envy is gonna be doing a lot
and and you know in terms of
investigating different things like one
thing that they're they're working to do
is try to have a software to where at
every checkpoint a player that wants to
enter whether it's it's the arena
whether it's the hotel whether it's the
facility where they work out like all
these different places that they're
gonna have at their disposal whether
it's the 24/7 lounge where they're able
to swipe their magic band and if it's
green they're able to be let through if
it's yellow or red or any other color
then they'll be investigated for further
health concerns now that is in the works
and that is I mean I that sounds so you
know futuristic to me like you can just
all you have to do is swipe this magic
band and it'll tell you if you're at
risk for coronavirus like that that's
pretty insane but you know that they're
gonna have special thermometers in each
play each campus numbers rooms that it's
called a smart thermometer that you know
you can apply daily and all of all the
feedback will go back to the league
health portal which will basically be a
tracking device from the moment the NBA
starts to this resumption in late June
you know coming up in the next week or
so to the end of whenever the finals end
so basically it's a constant monitoring
portal for them so they're trying to
come up with a lot of ways to make sure
that not only is everything going to be
tracked but you know we can stay ahead
of the game as much as possible more
than the average I guess human that's
amazing that's amazing so it's is it
possible again you know this is the
interesting aspect to me and I think for
a lot of fans to shams is that that will
the NBA be testing out testing in a way
that could be writ large that we could
all use to maybe go back to work and
open up societies I'm sorry the great
point that's a great point so the end
you know they're not going to utilize
this this breathalyzer or this saliva
test during this Orlando bubble but the
NBA is is involved in a Yale Health
Study that is going to allow their
players to participate and staffers and
whoever wants to participate in terms of
trying to figure you know basically
confirm yeah
testing and validate the testing and
confirm that this that their saliva
testing does work and so the NBA will be
funding that we'll be working hand in
hand with the LR mask and listen if it's
success that's clearly gonna be a test
I don't know how readily available will
be in the marketplace but confirmation
of that test where it's basically saliva
test away could go a long way whether it
is live whether it's a swab or whatever
the case may be so there's no question
they're trying to figure out ways you
know get this band you have a couple
rings that will tell you if you have
early detection they're they they are
trying to figure out ways that they can
use just for their season to go on now
we'll see if this be the things that'll
you know tack on to this everyday you
know American so are you saying that
again this is not something that the NBA
is going to use officially to rule
somebody in or out but it is something
that will be you know using the players
potentially as part of a study to see if
this material works for society as a
whole is that what you're saying yeah
yeah yeah they will be participating in
that study they participated in a couple
studies as Yale study a Mayo Clinic
study for antibodies that players have
participated in I'm told several teams
that participated in that one so there's
no doubt they're trying the testing that
will occur in the bubble will be a less
invasive nasal swab or a on oral swab
they're you know depending on which one
it is they might even do both and see
what the results of both are and
hopefully both are confirming the same
type of result making just be 100%
accurate but again the invasive nasal
swab unless you leave the bubble in your
caught that'll be out of the picture as
will this saliva testing that they will
be testing out can this magic band
figure out if James Harden's taking the
third step can we figure that out is
that possible
I don't think that's part of it's not
part of it okay that's not part of the
plan but in all seriousness I guess to
wrap this up what what if a third of a
team tests positive right before a
decisive Game seven right before a
pivotal Game five I mean
there's no real plan for that correct
it's just trying to avoid that that
everything is just in place to avoid all
that and then we'll see what happens
when should something like that happen
correct
I think I think you're right that it is
to avoid that they will allow
replacement players for coronavirus in
the bubble so if you are in game 6 of
the NBA Finals and your guy you know
says you have three guys maybe test
positive for chrono virus and you know
they're gonna be out for ten days and
you know the finals are over in four
days then listen I think it's time to
replace head players and and bring in
guys you know that can play and you know
what Adam silver did speak to players
about a month ago was if you know if
players do start testing positive with
some level of frequency Danby doesn't
want to halt play but perhaps they can
do a one or two day stoppage and then
come back but there's no big they're not
coming back just to stop again like they
did on March 11th this is you know once
once this ball gets rolling rich there's
no plan for them to get off shams Chang
thanks so much for the time and the
information you're it's impeccable
I appreciate that yeah I feel smarter
for for chatting with you thank you
appreciate it
thanks rich appreciate you got it you
got at centronia of stadium as well as
the athletic hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here